Machine learning is a method of data analysis
that automates analytical model building.
It is a branch of artificial intelligence based
on the idea that systems can learn from data,
identify patterns and make decisions
with minimal human intervention.
Because of new computing technologies, machine
learning today is not like machine learning of
the past. It was born from pattern recognition
and the theory that computers can learn without
being programmed to perform specific tasks.
The iterative aspect of machine learning is
important because as models are exposed to
new data, they are able to independently
adapt. They learn from previous computations
to produce reliable, repeatable decisions and
results. It’s a science that’s not new,
but one that has gained fresh momentum.
While many machine learning algorithms
have been around for a long time,
the ability to automatically apply complex
mathematical calculations to big data,
over and over, faster and faster, is a recent
development. Here are a few widely publicized
examples of machine learning applications you may
be familiar with. For example, the heavily hyped,
self-driving Google car, online recommendation
offers such as those from Amazon and Netflix,
knowing what customers are saying about you on
Twitter, and fraud detection, One of the more
obvious, important uses in our world today.
Why is machine learning important?
Resurging interest in machine learning is due to
the same factors that have made data mining and
Bayesian analysis more popular than ever. Things
like growing volumes and varieties of available
data, computational processing that is cheaper
and more powerful, and affordable data storage.
All of these things mean it's possible to quickly
and automatically produce models that can analyze
bigger, more complex data and deliver faster,
more accurate results, even on a very large scale.
And by building precise models, an organization
has a better chance of identifying profitable
opportunities, or avoiding unknown risks.
To create good machine learning systems, you
will need Data preparation capabilities ,
basic and advanced Algorithms, Automation and
iterative processes,Scalability,And, modeling.
There are some differences in nomenclature used
in machine learning versus traditional statistics.
For example, In machine learning, a target is
called a label. In statistics, a target is called
a dependent variable. A variable in statistics
is called a feature in machine learning.
And, A transformation in statistics is
called feature creation in machine learning.
Two of the most widely adopted machine
learning methods are supervised learning
and unsupervised learning, but there are
also other methods of machine learning.
Here's an overview of the most popular types.
Supervised learning algorithms are trained using
labeled examples, such as an input where the
desired output is known. For example, a piece of
equipment could have data points labeled either
failed or runs. The learning algorithm receives a
set of inputs along with the corresponding correct
outputs, and the algorithm learns by comparing its
actual output with correct outputs to find errors.
It then modifies the model accordingly. Through
methods like classification, regression,
prediction and gradient boosting, supervised
learning uses patterns to predict the values of
the label on additional unlabeled data. Supervised
learning is commonly used in applications where
historical data predicts likely future events.
For example, it can anticipate when credit card
transactions are likely to be fraudulent or which
insurance customer is likely to file a claim.
Unsupervised learning is used against
data that has no historical labels.
The system is not told the "right answer." The
algorithm must figure out what is being shown.
The goal is to explore the data
and find some structure within.
Unsupervised learning works well on transactional
data. For example, it can identify segments of
customers with similar attributes who can then
be treated similarly in marketing campaigns.
Or it can find the main attributes that
separate customer segments from each other.
Popular techniques include self-organizing
maps, nearest-neighbor mapping, k-means
clustering and singular value decomposition. These
algorithms are also used to segment text topics,
recommend items and identify data outliers.
Reinforcement learning is often used for robotics,
gaming and navigation. With reinforcement
learning, the algorithm discovers through
trial and error which actions yield the
greatest rewards. This type of learning
has three primary components: the agent, the
learner or decision maker. the environment,
everything the agent interacts with. and actions,
what the agent can do). The objective is for the
agent to choose actions that maximize the
expected reward over a given amount of time.
The agent will reach the goal much
faster by following a good policy.
So the goal in reinforcement
learning is to learn the best policy.